so right now the media's face is pressed
up against the window of the candy store
and they're salivating the glass fogged
hoping against hope staring into a field
of dreams believing if they build an
impeachment a crime will surely come so
let's step back and see this for what it
is another example of the media and the
dams fashioning the worst of things out
of the best of times all to avenge an
emotional loss you want some examples
well as America leads the way in climate
with cleaner energy the left tells their
kids we have a decade to live as race
relations improve from the mass
demonstrations of five years ago the
media sees racism in every nook as men
and women reach equality in all facets
the media questions whether gender is
just a fantasy and as women and
minorities gain more employment than
ever the guy running the show is called
a bigoted sexist a guy called Trump a
guy who wakes up every morning in that
candy store called America wondering
what we can get out of the world and not
the reverse for him it's not about money
influence or sex god knows he's had
enough of that for five lifetimes it's
about the job and you're his boss see
he's a guy who is stingy with both blood
and treasure which is why he's trying to
replace real wars with trade wars he's
sending in accountants instead of tanks
and yet even as America is governed by
an orange Gandhi the median Dems see him
as Hitler you see the trend as the world
gets better which the metrics show the
media panics how can they report good
times
if Trump's involved in all of them so
every day is doomsday since 2016 which
is why now they're outside that candy
store waiting for that sweet impeachment
desperate for the taste of revenge the
sweetest bond bond of all Holt applause
Dana while Donald Trump was talking
apparently like the other networks were
cutting in and out to fact-check him
isn't that nice with would they ever do
that to a bomber you think no dare they
but hopefully we wouldn't either right
yeah the thing if you want to take the
president speech take it yeah but look
everybody to each their own however you
want to get your coverage and then
you know our viewers I do think when it
comes to the media for example earlier
there was a story that broke around four
o'clock the Washington Post said that
the Acting Director of National
Intelligence was threatening to quit
yeah because he was not going to be
allowed to speak freely and the press
secretary at the White House said the
why not the Washington Post gave us
literally six minutes to respond that's
her words I don't know exactly what
happened that's what she said mm-hmm and
I know what it's like you're at Unga
you've got six minutes really wait I got
a call the DNI you got a chip with the
National Security Advisor you got to
call the CIA I mean there's you can't do
all of that in six minutes they went
with a story it goes out there all of a
sudden then you have the Acting Director
of National Intelligence say that's not
true yeah I never threatened to quit
I've never I was never gonna quit he
will be on the hill tomorrow I do think
when it comes to all of this the the
breathlessness of the reporting is
always good to remind ourselves that
waiting for more information is always a
better answer and I do think that that
is true for the Democrats as well I find
it really curious that Nancy Pelosi who
had been so cautious and put and kind of
like off-putting to her the rest of her
caucus saying we're not going to go for
impeachment right now this bad politics
we don't have anything there's no
smoking gun we don't have the evidence
and yet they do this before they get the
transcript seems to me like they went
out on the lam and then sawed it off she
was like eh she was like hesitantly she
didn't want to kick that soccer ball
into the net she but she felt oh they're
screaming at me the bass is screaming at
me Katie what happens if they actually
undo an election have you thought it
through how happy how happy America
might respond if they try to impeach a
president based on a phone call what
would happen well Mike Pence will be
President and they'll be much less much
much worse so maybe they should think
about this twice yes yeah it's amazing
how they continue to talk about the need
to protect democracy and the voting and
all this stuff but yet they are now
going down this road of reversing an
election that they don't like and
they've done this through a number of
steps through the the Russia
investigation this phone call now and we
haven't been able to name any kind of
high crime in misdemeanor that any of
them can cite properly with any kind of
evidence and the question is is the
media ever going to learn anything I
mean are the activists or they reporters
because a lot of the stuff and the
Muller report was supposed to
show everything that happens rob robber
molar was supposed to breathe life into
the report none of that happened
and here we are now with the transcript
which doesn't show the quid pro quo
which was reported yesterday multiple
times it doesn't mention Joe Biden
nearly as many times as reported and yet
there's no correction from quite frankly
anybody about the fact that they got
this wrong and I wonder if they sit
around in newsrooms and never have a
conversation about how they can do
things better because there's a lot you
know Jesse this is like another textbook
example of the accelerating mob saw out
with Covington you saw with Kavanagh all
this is gonna do is red pill another
three or four million Americans yeah I
don't trust the media anymore after they
screwed up royally on the Russia hoax
and they did it again with Kavanagh and
now they've done it again with this
story they got way out in front of over
their skis and it looks like it was a
big nothing burger am I allowed to say
nothing burger I don't like nothing but
shopping nothing burritos I'm gonna
nothing buried nothing burrito if it's
fun I want to go back to something that
Juan said he said it is a crime what is
the crime exactly one I think that he
was asking a foreign government to
interfere in American pop that statutory
crime number one number two isn't that
exactly what the Obama administration
did Miller we've been authorized to help
spine from campaign never and but never
asked an ally okay so the British were
involved in smuggling
excuse me Italian okay ball say stress
excuse me the United States intelligence
community in the process of gathering
information said we had conversations
with people in Britain overseas okay so
that the Obama administration okay so
the Obama FBI and CIA or the Obama thing
want go back to school all right here
also how is this they say this is not
even a campaign violation that that's
the level of the crime it's not even a
campaign violation because there's
nothing a thing of value attached to it
okay yeah inference there's no okay okay
so the how did this Hillary Clinton
the nine million she sent overseas to
get Russian dirt on Trump that they used
a spy on them that's not a thing of
value but this is I think diamonds not
even
and this is his son that the non
Democrat nominee son getting looked into
was the Obama team at the time during
the presidency was uncomfortable with
the judgment that hundred Biden was
exercising and good for them and but but
then but didn't do anything about it
right that we know of maybe they were
maybe they staved off other thing do you
think they would allow hunter Biden to
freelance and Ukraine while his dad's
running point well that's rich rooms
like how would they ever allow that and
the China example could be worse and and
that story was going to come out so both
of these things that Nancy Pelosi was
hoping we're not going to come to
fruition or at least not right away
impeachment and the hunter Biden and the
and the questions into the bite and
whole extravaganza you know this the
trip to China on Air Force two those
were two things that she was trying to
stave off now they are front and center
and one thing about the election we're
in the middle of a Democratic primary
lots of Democrats running for office we
saw up 20 Biden has been able to defy
gravity and all of these polls for a
long time with one key issue
electability yeah so now his polls
number his poll numbers have started to
come down Elizabeth Warren's have been
on the rise but there's still a lot of
time there could be changes if you are a
Democrat today and the only thing you
want it to beat President Trump in 2020
and your key issue is electability does
any of this make you feel like Joe Biden
could be more vulnerable in 2020 and I
think the answer is yes and you'll see
photos oh and let me just say why I
don't think so first of all what you got
is I mean you were suggesting earlier oh
you know Nancy Pelosi is out on a limb
has been sawed off in fact more people
after the release of today's memo are
saying you know what
we're behind impeachment and I think
you're going to send a choice and of
[ __ ] in the polls as well and when it
comes to you was founded a poll about
Joe Biden and Beau Biden
this has so been investigated so much
Peter Schweitzer is the one who started
this with his book back in 2018 and then
you see a lot of this echoing a bit of
chamber and you know what those people
have searched through this yeah and it
has our
as a comedian overs for oh this is all
you have was wrong the thing about this
is you say oh it's the media is the
media not supposed to report when the
President of the United States engages
great montage I think we're gonna
compare two different kind of examples
of the media there was this Russian
versus now I think that's what we're
doing
why not certainly say with confidence
that there is significant evidence of
collusion there's a crime it's on the
statute books and crimes are typically
impeachable offense the beginning of the
end of the Trump presidency this is
about a commander-in-chief who actually
is meddling with America's national
security what we're seeing is worse than
Watergate I keep getting asked are there
echoes of Watergate in this and there
are two quick 82 quote CNN same playbook
different day that's how they talk about
Trump then we're talking about
themselves and if you look at the
credibility of who's making these
arguments people are gonna say okay
President Trump has been right about
this and people like Adam Schiff and
people in the media have been wrong
they've never produced the evidence that
they promised and I gotta say Democrats
better be careful what they wish for
because every time they call for one of
these investigations yes people start
looking around about what's going on and
it always come back comes back to prove
that they've been accusing president
Trump and Republicans of exactly what
they've been doing and so there are
serious questions about whether again
Joe Biden was selling influence through
the son hunter Biden and whether these
deals were being made as a result of his
where's that coming from
I definitely hear the hunter Biden
questionable judgment thing but that Joe
Biden no I did financially no I'm saying
hunter Biden benefited financially from
his father because because they said I
want to get cleaned up you know getting
in you know what amazes me
because you guys keep bringing up Obama
yes imagine if the Obama asked a foreign
leaders like take an hour can my lawyer
rudy giuliani or can my attorney general
a bill our kid involved with more
investing one should remember the united
states if he think someone has committed
a crime he can go to the in assist
apartment and say we need to investigate
me overseas investigation was it's a
counterintelligence investigation under
the auspices of the commander in chief
he said that they did it for obama
criminal in other words obama is the one
who leaves it did I did that Russia is
another had some incur interference in
the election to benefit Donald Trump
that was saying this isn't investigated
fully and no one ever found anything
nobody's diplomat goes to the Trump
Tower Hotel orders a cocktail and
liberals fire up when they want to like
investigate and impeach over the
emollients Joe Biden's son takes a
billion from the Chinese and you think
it's not been investigated solely that's
in in other words so Jim Comey who's a
Republican Robert Moses Republican
hypocrite because what happened today
with this we now know no sawing off of a
branch we now know that this president
tried to get a foreign power involved in
America everybody what's great everybody
in America is going to read the
transcript and then it's good then
everybody's gonna go what a bunch of
garbage the media lied to us again